القوات العراقيه تقاتل اخر جيوب ميليشيات
داعش في الفلوجه يقول المسؤولون انهم قد
حرروا المدينه الاستراتيجيه التي تبعد 40
ميلا فقط عن
بغداد يقول احمد علي الذي يعمل ضمن قوات
مكافحه الارهاب العراقيه ان اليوم هو اخر
يوم للمعركه في الفلوجه وانهم قد حرروها
تماما تعتبر خساره المدينه اخفا لداعش من
خلال حرمانها من نقطه انطلاق مناسبه
للهجمات على بغداد واثناء قتالها لتحرير
المدينه وجدت القوات العراقيه مصنع
القنابل هذا التابعه لداعش لكن العبوات
الناسفه والافخاذ المتفجره ما زالت منتشره
ابقاء الفلوجه خاليه من داعش واحكام
السيطره على المدينه ذات الاغلبيه السنيه
تحد بالنسبه للحكومه ذات القياده
الشيعيه اتوقع ان تستمر المناوشات في
الفلوجه بعد اليوم لكن اعتقد اننا نرى
اخبارا ايجابيه جدا
تعتبر الخسائر البشريه مذهله فالظروف
متدهوره بالنسبه لمن فروا من الفلوجه
والمناطق المحيطه بها والذين تقدر الامم
المتحده اعدادهم ب 85 الف شخص هربوا منذ
بدايه الهجوم العراقي لاستعاده المدينه
قبل شهر وتلوح ايضا في الافق معركه اكبر
بكثير لتحرير الموصل ثاني اكبر مدينه شمال
العراق وقد بدات بالفعل الغارات الجويه
لعزل مواقع داعش وحصلت سي ان ان على هذه
لضربه موجهه الى موقع يضم مقاتلين اجانب
سيكون من المهم جدا تنفيذ الغارات الجويه
ببالغ الدقه بسبب وجود المدنيين في
المدينه المكتظه بمليوني
شخص التحدي هو ايجاد اهداف للغارات بحيث
لا نلحق الضرر بالمدنيين دون قصد لكن
الغارات الجويه وحدها لن تكون كافيه
فالاختبار الاكبر للقوات العراقيه على
الارض لم ياتي بعد